thank you everyone for coming my name is
Robert axelsson besides from organizing
this Meetup I'm also going to give a
talk to you today on the topic on the
topic of deploying a VPN a VPN is a
virtual private network that enable is
it for you to connect to that server or
that network from your connection when
you are connected to the Internet and it
gives room for you to encrypt your data
and also to bypass as a proxy if your
server VPN network is in the US it will
appear most probably for the person that
you are accessing the website at for
example cnn.com or whatever that you are
coming from the US and not from Austria
but let's get into the details and why
I'm mentioning this today what I'm going
to cover in specifics is outline which
is a tool that enables you to set up
your own virtual private network
we'll get to the specifics soon my name
is Robert axelsson as I mentioned you
can find me at Rob Axelson on most of
the things I didn't realize I put this
in here but I am actually on all the
things at on all the things as well I
haven't started using it actively but I
have it everywhere and it's an alliance
for now I might do something fun with it
but it was just available I'm at I'm on
all the things at on all the things I am
a software developer a meetup organizer
and a community enthusiast I like
creating and starting and organizing
meetups I now run three monthly meetups
as you know as I mentioned before yeah
if you want to learn more about mine and
also Corgan eyes with daniel deutsches
journey from learning to program to code
to getting our first developer job which
we did recently over the last couple
couple of years both me in him you can
look online at my website you'll find
links to recordings of that talk with it
ok enough about me
slides for this talk are already
available online in a repo
so have a look there also for the ones
looking at the recordings just head on
over there and you can look at the
slides together no need to take notes
what inspired this talk for me was
recently I think within the last week
there was episode YouTube at hack 5
which by the way is a great YouTube
channel a big shout out to them if
you're interested in security or
penetration testing or hacking be it
white hat - a hat or black hat have a
look at that channel they've been around
forever and there's some really great
stuff there down to beginner intros on
what to do in the command line to using
Kali Linux and all kinds of stuff so I
really really really recommend to have a
look if you have any interest in that
topic okay so before we get into the
tool that we're going to use let's get a
little bit of see a little bit serious
and let's talk about a guy named John so
John a 27 year old journalist ever since
he was a young teen he learned about the
widespread corruption in this country
after experiencing it firsthand himself
he has been driven to stop it
John from an early age again he
volunteered to help with the school
paper and he learned that he had a
talent for writing it was only natural
to him that he applied to study
journalism in the capital in the
university in the capital of his country
and he was ecstatic when he got accepted
like this is awesome so John again after
having studied for a couple of years he
graduated with flying colors he easily
got a job at the top newspaper in his
country and John he was on a path he was
really destined to be to get a great
career career but he wanted something
more he's this ease that should have
been - here because it looks like he has
a disease so sorry for that but his this
is with a - regarding corruption has
never really faded since his teens but
his country had only a resemblance of a
free press
and writing about corruption was a best
friend upon still he felt repelled to
speak up then out of the blue so John
was suddenly contacted by an anonymous
source that had him introduced to John
via common friend and led to believe
that he'll help disclose scandal then
involved highly powerful men and their
corruption in their country so John
agreed to meet a secret location was
will upon and they met and John was both
shocked and repulsed by the scandal his
source revealed but he knew he get had
to get a story publish the end shortly
after the meeting John mysteriously went
missing and John's story was never
published even though this is a
fictional story clearly written by me
today
mixing past and present tense and not
work of great we'll get to that
afterwards nor the work of great writing
talent it tells the story that I think
the people behind Outland wants to tell
and help mitigate to confuse you I'll
jump back in my slides because I'm think
I'm missing or there is also so outline
was released now in March of this year
by jigsaw which is alphabets Cyber
Security Division supposedly by
TechCrunch stating it's their
cybersecurity division looked a little
bit into it it looks more like they're
an incubator under alphabet alphabet
owns Google if you didn't know so this
is Google backed that has to do with
geopolitical issues and how to help the
world or people better protect those
spaces so not strictly cybersecurity but
it definitely
philately falls under that domain yes
that's jigsaw I wanted this talk to be a
bit again back to the title deploy to be
a bit interactive I want to state this
because I'll get back to it later
this talk is this YouTube video is 7 17
minutes long and will cover some stuff
that I won't cover today what we'll
cover now together is going to the
website downloading the tool and then
installing it and setting up our own VPN
and hopefully the demo gods are with us
and the internet is stable and we'll see
if we can get this done so let's do this
our two links we need there one is the
website to download it the other one is
my referral link to the place we can use
us for hosting a VPS for hosting this
keep in mind if you use this link you
will get $10 credit I will get some
credit on my part if you prefer not to
do it it'll be apparent later on in the
talk where you can go to do it without
involving me I want that to be perfectly
clear because I'm not doing this yeah
for those reasons and I just a super
quick shout out we my company are
looking for both front end and back end
developers if you are interested here
are the details contact me email or
check on the website yeah I'm a
front-end developer in my team we use
vue.js javascript mainly have a look if
you're interested cool so let's do this
it's as simple as using the link going
to get outline org
they are framing this for journalists
but keep in mind you could use this
yourself you would have to pay for the
hosting we'll get into that as a monthly
cost but when you have set it up you can
buy click of a few buttons send a link
to your friend or contact whatever you
want to connect with via a VPN
encrypted securely and privately as you
can get there's always potential
loopholes and with humans involved and
attack vectors like I want I cannot
stand on stage to say you will be 100%
secure but as secure as we can get in
this day and age and then you can invite
them and they'll be connected via your
VPN and you can safely communicate with
them one thing to add about what we're
going to do or note that the reason for
using such a tool is not just for
journalists if you are connected let's
say in at Starbucks which is notoriously
one of the examples for you shouldn't
check your online banking if you're a
Starbucks or any open Wi-Fi network
because anyone that just puts up
computer and know something they can
sniff the data and they'll figure all
this stuff out this is a safe as you can
get by still being connected in a public
open Wi-Fi first before you share
anything private or sensitive you
connect via the VPN and then you proceed
to communicate what you want it to be
hidden or you log in to your online bank
or you log into Facebook or whatever you
don't want anyone else to possibly be
able to snoop read so that's also a use
case besides the journalism stuff so we
just scroll down and we go to get lot
outlet managers there's by the way also
mobile clients hak5 mentioned that it's
not covered on all the devices for me it
seems like so but there might be some
some caveats there but for our
demonstration now we'll just go and get
for Linux you can also download so you
can initially set this up we have Izzard
on Windows or Mac OS and we'll see why
that is the case it's downloading down
here now and over half the way through
so we'll just wait for that in the
meantime I'll get up a terminal
and will soon get going so for those of
you who aren't so tactical or you don't
even have to be technical to note
understand what's going on right now but
I'm on Linux and what I do now might
seem esoteric the only thing I'm doing
is opening the file so at Windows you
would just double-click the egg Exe file
and what would happen by itself a little
bit more complicated here but it's just
a couple of lines of code or command
line commands so I just have to give it
I won't go into details the one that
knows what this is knows it so now I'll
just execute it apparently not
okay
uh-huh
what
plus-x thank you shout out to however
spot at the error we got it now
there we go so hey we get it let's see
maybe I'll break it now yeah we cannot
maximize it so this is the biggest we
get I'll go a step back because I see it
knows I already started this earlier
today so I'll sign out this is what it
will look like for you when you just
open this up the first time it does
expect you to have an account that
digital ocean deep little ocean is a VPS
a virtual private server provider they
compete in the space against the Amazon
and Google Cloud and so on
they more are in the business of giving
you a dedicated virtual server at them
the certain amount of power and then you
pay per month and you do whatever you
want with them
and with it you can start as low as five
dollars a month and that's what this is
based on so you have to pay five dollars
to try this out first you do create an
account you can do that via here or you
can use the link I mentioned rubley go
do and you get $10 credit to start this
out right now I just have to sign in
awesome I don't think you have to agree
to any gdpr compliance and sign any
papers to see my email but this we had a
talk before let me just get my mobile
ready so I can do the second two factor
authentication here and I have to change
the password to do this this doesn't
work but we should be covered so you see
you see my second email awesome
you can hear from the way I'm typing
what my password is awesome awesome so I
just gonna get my one of my account
passwords awesome so so you create your
account and you just sign in now it
might prompt me for something awesome so
give me one second
okay so here's the magic and this is
where I found this really great for our
meetup today that with this digital
ocean you can choose a country that the
server is in that's also on topic today
you can choose it to be in the EU for
example and also we're very close to
Frankfurt so that's awesome
then I'm pressing the button and I'm
telling it to set it off for me it is
doing that and this might take two
minutes it says while we're doing that
once this is done what we will see will
be inside my digitalocean account and
then we'll see that it actually has
created a new server and if you are
interested if you do this it's an entry
port to be able to log in to your own
server and get a little bit of feel of
what Linux is and system administration
because it starts with these small
experiments it did for me I was like
what is this VPS can i host besides
using Hostgator or one-and-one or one of
these hosting providers how much
knowledge will it need to do it on my
own and before I learned to program the
free code camp I took a course at Linux
Academy and learned to host the other
lamp stack limit Linux Apache my sequel
and PHP using these kind of tools online
and if I didn't want to use the VPS
anymore after a day I could just destroy
it I don't only pay for that one or two
days but it's a great way for learning
these kind of things now we see that
there is already so this kept going on
in the background I'm just going to
refresh for the sake of clarity what
this did in the background was that this
is my normal server and I'm giving you
the IP address this is awesome so I
should probably change that it's fine
it's fine
if you know my domain name you can find
this IP address publicly available this
is the one the server that it created
this is its unique IP address so if you
try to attack this IP address as a
hacker or whatever what you are just
directing at is the VPN
server that we just set up by clicking
above so it can be done magically easy
like this now the thing I won't go into
detail upon now is how you would share
this because the video that I mentioned
earlier then I have a link to goes into
better detail of explaining this and for
me to demo this on this desktop I would
need also to have a shared screen of a
phone or another desktop to show the
interaction what's going on right so
that does that much better we can do
that at a key part I'm not connected
okay get connected connect this device
okay
it gives us some stuff to install so I
won't do that now with you because
that's to doesn't give you anything the
only thing we see after this is done is
that I can click a key to share with
someone else but we have done the hard
part already believe me so we're almost
done we're almost true but keep in mind
that you can use something like
digitalocean to do these kind of things
on your own either for a VPN and you can
be ready in a second or you can do it
for different services if you want to
host WordPress on your own if you're
interested in trying out Linux if you
want to do something like you've heard
about this ghost alternative to
WordPress or you want to set up instead
of github you want to set up gitlab for
yourself for your team if you want to
play around with my sequel there's a lot
of stuff that are already there for you
with the click of a button mean stack
for example is MongoDB nginx
angular and nodejs
so on topic for free code camp it's a
Java Script paste and if I click here
now so I've chosen that one I can say I
want the minimum one I want to have it
in Frankfurt and I want to have ipv6 and
I want to add
my age always the public key is fine and
I can give it a name and create and it
goes through the same process again and
I'm gonna done with this I get an IP
address
I can SSH into it to means that I can
connect to it from my laptop
and I can be in an environment where I
can do start from the command line to
put stuff on my server to host stuff
create an app and already have it
available in IP so I don't have to just
have localhost on my computer so there's
tons of possibilities but that starts by
being curious about what virtual private
services what Linux is and how you can
do these things on your own and believe
me when I say anyone can learn it I
could I got it working and did it lotion
to top it off also has a great I can't
further find a link to it but they have
a great article base or they have a lot
of how to use on how to do these things
step by step really step by step anyone
can do this and you can also use these
tutorials and I really recommend it even
if you are not curious about
digitalocean at all if you're using
something else I would like to use
another provider they have a great
reputation for having really top-notch
articles and I go to them off and just
if there's something I'm curious about
myself and oh how do I do this I often
first go to digitalocean
so enough about them but I really mean
it when I say have a look there if
you're curious and to end the talk here
are the links not here they are and
thank you
[Applause]